[Applaudissements]
rêve d'un concert que je donnerai où je
pourrais me taire pendant 2 he et que
personne ne s'ennuie je rêve de me taire
et de passer mon temps à vous écouter
vous raconter je rêve de n'avoir plus
rien à
dire je rêve de passer mon temps à me
taire je rêve d'avoir le temps
d'embrasser tendrement chacune des
jeunes filles des femmes qui m'écoutent
ce soir je rêve de passer ma vie à
rendre visite à tout un chacun chez lui
à l'écouter je rêve de m'asseoir dans
les fauteuils de tout le
[Musique]
monde même si notre
histoire paraît
dérisoire dans le temps qui
fuit
même si elle est vine cette course
humaine vers quoi et vers qui ce petit
royaume sans majord d'omme c'est chez
lui jamais à la traain viens
silvantamène j'ai du
[Musique]
frasc ne crain pas la pluie de canard
tabille am man Sophie au petit royaume
sans
majordome chez
lui dans un coin de silence une mouche
danse sur un air de
gig des cheveux de neige des yeux qui
recherche on ne sa quoi
niqu ce petit royaume sans majord d'omme
chez
luoui un pied dans la tombe la morphe se
ronde et tu lui
souris sa fau est à la porte on sait
qu'elle est proche mais ce qu'il a
séduit
c'est ce petit royaume sans majord
d'omme chez
lui si tu passes outre si dans une
poutre on t'enferme
[Musique]
aussi tu passeras en douce comme sur de
la mousse vite en paradis dans ce petit
royaume sans
majordomme chez
[Musique]
lui